relations between the us and russia are
the worst
they've been in several decades now u.s
president joe biden and
russia's vladimir putin say they will
meet face-to-face in geneva next month
to
discuss all the issues between them the
two men have
met plenty of times before when biden
was vice president
this time it's different in his first
four months president biden
has expelled diplomats and hit moscow
with multiple rounds of sanctions
over allegations of russian interference
in the u.s election
over kremlin involvement in a cyber
attack and over the jailing of
opposition leader alexei navalny moscow
says putin is keen to discuss
everything from bilateral ties to
regional conflicts
and international challenges
let's talk about this uh with political
analyst ian bremmer
in new york he's the uh president of the
eurasia
group mr bremer how much of a surprise
is it that the kremen actually agreed to
hold this summit
oh it's not a surprise at all i i think
they like the prestige that comes from a
one-on-one sit-down with president biden
it makes them feel
more like equals which of course is the
way they want to be portrayed
internationally and i also think that
biden's happy with it i mean there is in
the united states right now a general
view that china is by far
the principal adversary of the united
states globally and the biden
administration would rather not have
untoward surprises from other parts of
the world
when they know that the china
relationship is unfixable and
deteriorating
and so i think both uh presidents were
relatively eager to get this set up even
uh with the complication the surprise
complication
uh of this blow up with belarus over the
last few days
so what do you think will be the main
talking points at this summit i think
cyber's going to be very
important uh the fact that the solar
winds attack
which was unprecedented in its scope
against the united states
i think that is an area where certainly
you would like to see
uh from both sides that we avoid
escalation
uh and so i think that'll be high uh on
on the agenda
uh i and and ukraine another area
where the united states is deeply happy
uh with
russia's behavior both historically and
ongoing but there are some areas where
there can be some cooperation as you
know the biden administration has
extended
the start agreement on nuclear forces
with the russians for five years
i think they'd like to see some movement
on further negotiations
around nuclear arms control and also the
blind administration would really like
to see the russians be more constructive
on climate
in the run-up to the cop 26 summit uh
coming up this fall
uh and there i expect there will be some
engagement directly with putin
well let's talk about the situation in
belarus at the moment and the forced
plane
landing uh joe biden has condemned this
this action
as outrageous and uh putin and
lukashenko are close allies will the u.s
president put more pressure on putin you
think
uh putin has not that's right uh and
but but it's pretty clear that putin was
not
involved in the decision to bring down
uh this airliner uh that uh that was
belarus
and luka shanka operating all by himself
um i i agree that uh putin's in a very
different perspective in terms of the
response but for me
the relationship between putin and
lukashenka is rather
similar to the relationship between xi
jinping
and kim jong-un in other words yeah
they're on the same side
but luka shank is kind of an irritant
that is going rogue
and you saw that um with the mishandled
reelection that lukashenko stole and the
necessity that lukashenka had
of of using enormous force against his
own civilians to stay in power
and now you see this uh with uh bringing
down this airliner and
it's interesting that putin has
basically summoned the belarusian
president to come to sochi
to meet next week i suspect that's not
going to be the easiest meeting
for the belarusian president stay with
us ian
because we'd like to talk to you some
more about belarus in just a moment to
remind our viewers
the country is currently facing further
isolation from the eu for forcing a
passenger jet
to divert to minsk in order to arrest
dissident journalist roman protosevich
belarusian airlines have been
banned from eu base and airports in
response and
those involved in the action will face
economic sanctions and
travel restrictions eu leaders have also
agreed to freeze a 3 billion euro
investment package
a little earlier german chancellor
angela merkel called once more for
protosavage to be released immediately
i can only describe it as worrying and
shocking as uk
prime minister boris johnson said that
makes our demands
all the more urgent that he must be
released that
everything must be done especially when
one hears what his parents have to say
and we will use all available means to
do this
german chancellor angela merkel speaking
there let's go back to political analyst
uh ian bremer in the eu
already had sanctions in place against
belarus and russia which appear to have
had little effect as even the french
president admits
what could be the next step
uh well you have to be impressed with
the fact that the europeans
responded quickly and uh in a unified
fashion
uh in terms of uh you know shutting down
belarus and airspace
for transit which is expensive for these
airliners
as well as not allowing gillaroosa's
flag carrier uh to
transit um to european uh cities but
this this is not as the french president
said earlier today
that this is not um going to be truly
punitive
in a way that will hurt uh luka shanka
now if they want to hurt him
they need to go after the oligarchs that
support him and they need to go
after the core sectors of the belarusian
economy that means
oil and that means potash and in
particular
all of the transit fees significant
transit fees that belarus gets from
transporting russian energy
across its territory into europe now if
the germans were to support
that that would really sting that would
make a difference
but i don't think they will um and uh
you know
absent those kind of broader sectoral
sanctions
i think that having protests in jail
who was a serious irritant for luka
shanka is a trade that he's very
happy with um for being you know having
rogue status with the europeans right
now
he feels impunity uh domestically
and increasingly he feels impunity with
the europeans that's a serious problem
well you mentioned the
the close ties between russia and and
belarus can sanctions against belarus be
separated from sanctions
uh sanctions against russia briefly if
you can
uh not if they involve uh the
energy that comes out of belarus because
it's russian energy
short of that you certainly can ian
bremer
president of the eurasia group thank you
very much for this insight
sure